verstörende bilder einer drohne aus der
ukraine
am rande eines kleinen wäldchens im
osten des landes bringt ein russischer
panzer ein weiterer bmw zwei panzer
versucht mit hoher geschwindigkeit das
brennende wrack zu überholen und
explodiert die beiden russischen panzer
sind in ein minenfeld gefahren der
hintere panzer fährt beim überholversuch
durchs feld ebenfalls auf eine mine auf
die explosion und trümmer lösen offenbar
eine weitere dritte mine aus oberhalb
der beiden zerstörten panzer sind
weitere krater zu sehen bild
militärexperten ordnen das video als
echt und aktuell ein warum der zweite
panzer nicht stoppt sondern zügig
versucht den zerstörten panzer links zu
überholen unklar
immer wieder kommt es für die russische
armee zu schweren panzer verlusten durch
artillerie oder raketenbeschuss
aber auch durch minen wie diese
verstörenden bilder deutlich machen